now it's my spoiler question sure um
spoiler warning for VHS 85 if you have
not watched the movie this is your time
to push pause go do something else watch
the movie and then come back and push
play on this video all right let's talk
about that that last shot now um many
questions I guess I'll start here for
the ultimate design of what Rory truly
is what would you say is the biggest
difference between like draft one
version one of that design and what you
wound up with in the finished film the
biggest difference from where we started
and where we ended up uh well I look in
the very beginning it really was just a
boy watching television and somewhere
along the way it derailed into something
all together and uh and and we really
love the idea of a you know a
metamorphosis something that was
changing uh it also felt right for the
rap because every time you come back to
the rap I think you're I hope you're
trying to figure out what the rap is yes
so you know Rory's transforming the
piece is transforming it starts as a kid
watching a television then you come back
to it as kid it's scientist watching a
kid watching a television you're going
what is this thing uh it's a documentary
for a while and then it's not and then
you get the raw footage of the entire
thing so uh uh yeah we just wanted to
keep the ball in the air so to speak uh
in the final design I will say was uh
was the last thing that we came to and
um and I called Keith Thompson the great
Keith Thompson who is designed I I've
worked with probably five times now and
uh and he always uh has a marvelous way
of digging into whatever we're up to and
bringing something weird and new to the
surface and really challenging us too
because he'll have a billion questions
on how something works and uh and Rory
was no exception so were there any
particular monster movie Inspirations
that you applied to that design we we we
did we watched uh Evan and I went uh we
got a cabin for a night and up in Big
Bear and we were just like okay what are
we going to do with this wraparound and
uh and we watched uh Dreamscape from
Beyond and video drum that night those
were you know we did wasn't a conscious
thing those were just the movies we put
on and uh uh metabolized that in some
way or another on drive back the next
morning this was what happened yeah yeah
I mean this just speaks to how often I
watch this movie a lot of the the
tentacle action made me think of uh
Independence Day in the lab scene yeah
there's like one there's one shot in
particular where one of the scientists
is pushed up against the door and you
see the tentacles coming into frame and
I'm like oh I like what that reminds me
up right now yeah beware filmmakers uh
when you commit to doing practical
tentacles in a Wier that was challenging
so I'll I'll end with this question
because you emphasized early on how
difficult this particular uh shot
sequence was can you isolate maybe the
toughest thing of the bunch the thing
that on set would make someone go I
can't believe that's what it looks like
on set but then that's what it looks
like on screen in the finished product
uh well the tentacles might be the
answer there I mean you know uh uh the
the Russell effects uh which did a
wonderful job on the piece um I mean you
know we always say when you're working
with practical stuff two frames to the
right and left of everything that's on
camera is just a total disaster you're
always you know it's always somebody in
a rubber suit with a crab claw trying to
you know make it look real uh in this
case uh we just had puppeteers hidden in
Corners behind doors hanging I mean we
had one Puppeteer who was on a ladder
leaning over a door who's basically out
of frame I it took a lot of strength
actually this tentacles are pretty heavy
and then uh uh and then the the the the
tentacles had a hose running through the
center of them so off camera there's
also somebody with an air compressor
just blowing air into it constantly so
the thing has life to it it's expanding
and um and it's always a bit
unpredictable when you have you know
monsters on a wire you don't really know
what's going to happen you don't really
know where it's going to land so you
shoot a lot of takes this is why I sit
in this seat why I love my job this kind
of movie Magic fascinates me to no end
and I appreciate the work that goes into
it so much huge congratulations on VH
VHS 85 hurry up make more of them
awesome always but thank
you